you're talking to a 20-year-old
gay mexican from texas so
get that [ __ ] straight and then she
immediately said okay well i'm sorry for
assuming
and i said okay well then again you you
assumed
all right time for bonus footage from
the latest change my mind that we taped
in austin you've seen some of the
conversations some of the
the heated debates uh but you haven't
seen this this just happened organically
we've noticed that when we show up and
do change my minds our location of
course gets posted and fans show up
and there's a really diverse intersect
of people and one trend we've really
noticed
is that there are a lot more gay
conservatives specifically
gay conservatives willing to talk about
their views than we've ever seen before
so
watch this and enjoy yeah you want to
sit down and just grab it
let's just talk here i'll i'll even let
you hold the mic because i'm pretty sure
you're not going to steal it
you know it is a nice looking mic there
you go yeah you can sit down yeah
all right just just give your name for
the camera and then you don't have to
address it again we just talked to you
and i yeah my name is josh
okay judge do you want me to hold the
mic or you want all the mic all right
i'll hold the mic i don't care i'll do
that okay so you were just saying so i
don't i'm not outing you right by saying
you're
right is that okay if i sit on camera
okay get so gay conservative
yep bisexual actually to
specify it which i guess a lot of people
like doing i was going to say
is that okay let me ask you this how
many people who claim to be bisexual are
actual bisexual do you think it's a do
you think a lot of them lie about it
just seem cool
i've had okay so personal story
no no actual names we'll just call him
mike right
let's let's call him mike his name's
mike isn't it mike's gonna see it she's
like that's my name
it's michael cover yeah it's clone guys
yeah okay we'll call him mike so mike uh
we were in a relationship for two months
nowadays i guess it's cool to just say
you know oh well i'm bisexual so
yeah yeah i get to do this i'm gay now
whatever and it's just like
i feel like as an actual bisexual guy
it's become a fad
and people always say all the time that
they
actually are interested in the other sex
okay
and i know i mean from a lot of
first-hand experience i know i'm getting
myself out there no i appreciate it
well isn't that that's an adorable dog i
don't know if you can see this sorry i'm
just
since this is relaxed that's the
greatest greater swiss mountain dog it's
beautiful
beautiful two good looking dogs sorry
i'm a big i'm a big dog guys so i get so
easily distracted we have two
people husky oh do you see that
oh guys the tolerant left strikes again
the tolerant left strikes again
yes but if you would like to change my
mind uh we were willing to have a
conversation of course
that's whole point is civil disagreement
okay
thank you no one not a lot of takers not
a lot of takers sadly i mean here in
austin texas there's a melting pot of a
city
you'd have thought a lot of people would
come up here and say well you know what
i disagree with that let me speak to
this guy
but do you think if they knew you were
gay they would have been they would have
said that they're probably not oh god no
oh god no dude oh god no
you do realize you get a pass to some of
that stuff they're like you're just like
hey man i'm gay like oh i'm so sorry
that's the funny thing is that people
always say to me you know they disagree
with a lot of
what i have to say i mean hence my shirt
um
it's a it's a general statement you know
but um
i have people actually someone actually
added me
on twitter uh because there was some
kind of like
nra discussion yeah and of course i try
men because
i i like you know speaking for another
side that a lot of people don't usually
see a lot of 20 year old gay mexican
kids go up to
and it was really funny because you're
mexican
dude tall mexican yeah i know right
that's i mean that's very uncommon i
know it's
true you're very tall i would have
guessed like you know spanish
but i know spanish have a bunch of
redheads too so never mind some
something like that i mean brazil is
just it's
colors yeah exactly and they're very
racist
brazil brazilians i know a lot of
brazilians are very racist sorry
so so the thing is uh actually someone
messaged me on twitter
and uh they said that why are you for
guns
now uh they brought up a lot of
statistics uh which i did too
and i brought up you know fbi cdc
something that you linked actually uh
for the
the cdc yeah the defensive uses exactly
i'm glad it helped yeah
so i brought that up in my defense and
someone called me a straight white
male that doesn't know anything about
that quote like word by word that's what
they said to me and
it was it was hilarious because i then
oh oh we have someone oh i think i think
you might disagree yeah do you mind if
we pick this up or we left off because
you know we gotta
that's the whole purpose to it all right
thank you yeah we'll see you around but
i have to follow up
mr straight white male over here and
he's not the only one here's another
friendly gay man with a mustache
or something sure yeah if you want to
get a picture you're what are you here
for the americans panel and for the uh
i'm working for the festival oh you are
yeah okay wow they must they must
be have a hard time with you well i
still i wore my
home pad during like the uh orientation
and i got a little angry
looks better whatever grab it yeah you
wanna grab a seat grab a picture i can
have uh
someone here take a picture for you what
was your name sir danny danny nice to
meet you danny oh my god sure
oh okay uh okay
you know what here hold on we can uh my
wife can take a picture here
thank you so much no problem yeah out
you're an awesome native yourself danny
uh i'm actually from houston
oh okay yeah and what got you involved
with the festival here
well i went last year and it was a lot
of fun you know i
i saw like some of my favorite
celebrities so okay
yeah i just wanted to uh get back to
like something that helped me out
all right i'm sorry no no don't worry
i just wanted to give back to something
that just brought me a lot of joy
sure yeah yeah do you do you find it
hard sometimes to kind of
see be a part of the activism that you
see from the festival in the panels is
that a tough pill to swallow
do you want me to do this no you don't
have to i mean if you if you want i was
just kind of sitting down but i think
yeah i can hold this for you
sure all right do you want to hold it
i'll hold it i guess we've had people
try to steal it so
you don't look like the type but you
know well it is a little difficult
but um you know
i live in austin so i'm not like really
i'm not really trying to make friends
politically i'm just trying to make
friends just socially
and you know if we if we meet
someone that's like or if i meet someone
that's like super
conservative or at least like moderate
then yeah we
have a good friendship based off that
i'm trying to hit it off amazing
like okay so i don't want to be foreign
let me ask you are you
uh what's your orientation
i'm bisexual okay so but i'm not
offending you by asking you yeah yeah no
you're fine
so we've had a lot of the last two days
uh actually fighting off yesterday was a
bisexual but a lot of
gay or bisexual conservative fans come
out
cool do you feel like there's a ground
swell happening i guess maybe since the
same-sex marriage is kind of off the
table that it's like hey i can be
bisexual
and also want lower taxes because it's
surprised us
how many have shown up and been just
really friendly great great people
yeah yeah yeah i definitely would say
like there's this new wave of
conservatism now
that just like they don't give a [ __ ]
about like gay people it's like
if you're not killing anybody you know
yeah exactly
that's what this is about killing you
know who we believe exactly exactly
no it was funny because uh i'm on like
this group chat now and they're like
[ __ ] freaking out about this or they
left
oh no well can you be our eyes and ears
and if they want to do anything violent
let us know
got you back man i appreciate well thank
you so much man i appreciate
i appreciate being in the fray i know i
know it's not easy you know
as crazy as it sounds i know white male
privilege but as a christian
conservative
white male in french socialist canada
yeah i didn't have a lot of friends
either
so uh we always appreciate and we always
we always
want people out there if they feel like
outsiders or feel like they don't have a
place
you're always welcome okay thank you i
appreciate it and uh
yeah enjoy the rest thank you very much
appreciate it stay hydrated
i know it's unbelievable that was fun
back to the first guy he had to duck out
for a little second actually that's why
it's edited but he's back now
i'm sure remember where we were uh white
male privilege
because of your nra discussion oh yes
yes okay yes so
so that's pretty funny okay as a tall
gay mexican
as a tall game mexican uh well
i let them know of past i i guess i let
them know of my past of discrimination
from my own self sure i came out of the
closet
at around 15 years old and as
much as people would love to say
everyone is so tolerant here in austin
this is austin
everyone's so nice yeah i still had my
fair share of people you know
just telling me about how they
disagree which i'm poor you know i'm for
if hey if you disagree with my lifestyle
if you disagree with anything i have to
do sure that's that's your right
yeah that's your right i i can't govern
how you think and it doesn't mean that
they hate you either
exactly you know so i i know plenty of
friends actually two of my good friends
are still against gay marriage yet they
completely support me and they
completely support my livelihood
they care about me that's just something
they cannot agree with based off of
religious standpoints which
that's what i was going to ask you about
do you feel like you were kind of
talking about this
since the gay marriage issue is kind of
off the table do you think you'll see a
lot more
gay people uh and minorities in general
become conservative because we've seen a
lot at our show
oh definitely definitely yeah the big
thing
that a lot of people love to assume
is that every single gay person that
you're going to meet is going to be a
i bleed blue democrat yeah that is
completely wrong i it doesn't matter now
that the gay marriage thing has moved
off the table and by the way
there were a lot of gay people i knew
who either didn't support it or didn't
care there was like civil union fine
even including elton john
but now that that's been removed i just
don't understand what's like
why you can't be a guy who prefers a man
over women and also not like to pay high
taxes it doesn't
i don't see the correlation exactly and
and i don't either
and especially with everything that's
been going on right now i heard that the
supreme court uh ruled in the favor of
that oregon bakery
yeah instead of the gay couple i'm for
that
i'm for people having their own right to
service
who they want and first of all by the
way they would serve the gay couple they
just wouldn't bake the cake for the
wedding wedding for the wedding exactly
and that's something that i completely
agree with if you're going over to a
private
and that that's the big that's the big
term that a lot of people didn't
understand
everyone thought it's a company saying
no to gay people and they don't want to
support the gay people because they
don't want to buy a cake
and it's just like no it's a private
company it's
it's run by a a wife and a husband
that are like pretty older and they just
wanted to say
no to making the cake for the wedding it
goes against their
religious views right i would never you
know force
a jewish person to ever or jewish uh
bakery to ever say oh you know what even
though i am prone you know neo-nazi and
stuff like that
go pick me bake me the swastika cake
dude it's hey you know it goes against
you
that's a joke right i don't know i've
seen some mexican neo-nazis
you know you never know today he's
excited he's a gay mexican neo-nazi
uh well you know i always have to be
careful cause like i said the guy who
walked off was like just the jews and
yelled it out to try and attribute it to
me
oh yeah so i always have to make sure
that i'm like that's a joke correct
some people don't like but but do you
use it you have to admit right like you
use it as a
you must use it as a pass like if
someone yells like [ __ ] you if you're
like hey i'm gay
do you see them clam up oh of course of
course i'm so sorry
of course i have people i i have someone
assuming
my race my sexuality someone called me
on
of course a buzzfeed twitter post
i know i know i dove into dark territory
there for a sec
right but uh i was there and uh it
someone just said well straight white
males shouldn't matter
your voice and your opinion doesn't
matter and i said okay first of all
[ __ ]
hold up you're talking to
a 20-year-old gay mexican
from texas so get that [ __ ] straight and
then she immediately said
okay well i'm sorry for assuming and i
said okay well
then again you you assumed right you
assumed
does does your opinion matter now it
matters more because you're getting
mexican somehow it matters more that you
know
use it we need you i do i do
i do and i just got on twitter i've been
on there for about a month
i already have like 150 followers and of
course all my friends are just like hey
look josh you gained another 80 year old
white person from tennessee and i'm just
like no i
i gained another person that agrees with
my standpoints right
you know yeah it shouldn't matter what
they look like
what they do where they live because
when it comes
at the okay at the end of the day when
it comes down to it
my viewpoints are always for the better
of everyone
in america right in america which is why
i'm actually
or building the wall yeah because it
betters everyone for america legal
immigrants
come over here exactly legal immigration
come over here for the better
of themselves and for their livelihood
and for their families well we talk
about this quite a bit we just talked
about on the show on thursday
you can either have equal opportunity or
equal outcomes you can't have both
you know so if someone says well we have
to have a certain quota of gay people or
we have to have a certain quota of women
in applied sciences
what does that do it removes equal
opportunity for the guy who really
deserves that spot
of course you have to pick one and we're
in this era and i think a lot of
minority voters including you know using
the umbrella term including gay voters
do you feel like do you feel like um
because i know you're more conservative
and obviously your partner was more
liberal and now more conservative do you
think there's a groundswell
where minorities uh gays included or
alternative lifestyles
have realized that their votes have been
taken for granted of course
of course definitely every every person
that is okay let's say for instance
um the leading democrat right now in
austin
is beto it's beto something you see all
over austin
yeah uh like vote for beto vote for veto
vote for beto
and uh the guy i respect him as a man i
respect everyone
you know like religious political every
viewpoint ever aside
right i respect every human being and
i feel like a lot of my friends i have
one of my friends and yeah i'm going to
shout you out nikos if this is on a
video
but he is from uh jesus california of
course
he's from california of course and uh he
always says
you know oh well i disagree with that i
disagree with that i disagree with that
and i say well why why
and he says in response he'll give his
viewpoint i'll give my viewpoint
and it ends at that but there are a
couple times where he does say
you know what hold on because
i i've even i've even asked him like hey
and chris when did i ask him when did i
ask him a long time ago but i i asked
him
it was about two months ago i said hey
do you think that now you've been living
in and he
he lived here in austin we went to high
school together he lived here in austin
and i think these people might disagree
so oh yeah but i want you to have your
story yeah of course
so um he actually he lived in california
and i said to him
hey ever since you know you've been here
and you moved away
and you've talked to me ever since do
you feel like maybe your viewpoints are
now
not as you know as appointed to
democratic
values and he says well yeah yeah
definitely and i tell them well why is
that
he said well you bring up stats you
bring up facts and of course uh
like ben shapiro i only care about
the stats the facts give me that
information and i will base
my judgment off of that i'm glad that
that helped you to so that you used some
of our stats and that cdc stat is so
important in the gun debate
and i'm amazed that more people don't
talk about it because remember they said
the nra wanted to block
gun research well that same cdc research
is the most damning research that's come
out
and now no one talks about it oh no one
does no just just look at the numbers
500 000 to 2 million i think it's to 3
million if it's a cdc one but there's
another one that's 500 000 2 million
there's one to five but at least 500 000
to 2 million yeah
compared to if you remove suicides
twelve to fifteen thousand exactly it's
not even close yeah and there's still
people in texas there's still people in
the united states that do not agree with
me and him being together they don't
agree with this ring on my finger
i don't even see it it's it's it's
see-through yeah
exactly you don't want to let them know
too much no
but uh oh [ __ ] we haven't even announced
our engagement to your parents well
hey believe that we never believe these
we'll just bleep it there you go
sorry well if they do find out from a
video from a stephen crowder video
that'd be even better
yeah yeah well so sorry wait
hey sorry sorry mom and dad-in-law your
kid's gay
like really gay but they seem happy good
guys you know
that's what gay that's what gave me
you're doing well yeah we're doing
pretty good you get his head moving on a
little bit i could see him i could see
you guys get into some arguments you
know he'd probably be the one to throw
the first blow but
you know i mean yeah probably boxing for
14 years
go there you go nothing like you're
probably the one to throw the first blow
but oh yeah oh
that's true great there's a distinct
mexican fighting style too you know i do
boxing as well i did you for a long time
with my knees
and uh yeah unbelievable boxers from
mexico like they're just it's just
reality
they're great boxers oh yeah of course
but they're not very big
they tend to dominate lower weight
classes five eight that's why you could
be the first uh you see the first
cruiserweight
i'm coming well first you gotta come out
of the closet but
there you go i think we have some more
people to come on up but thank you so
much man thanks amigo i appreciate it
hey if you liked this video you could
subscribe oh my god
subscriber hit the notification bell
which is right next to the subscription
button because subscriptions don't mean
anything anymore or you can watch the
late night late night show every single
day at lotto with crowder.com we get
this hand-etched mug all these other
shows
and you can subscribe and watch it every
day so we can keep doing this because
youtube doesn't want to pay us a letter
with clutter.com subscribe notification
bell
someone call 911